chapter 274 of ma here academia has just
cemented this walk as my favorite in the
entire series up until now I would have
said probably the Oval Hawk was my
favorite but I can't deny any longer
this is straight up the most exciting
stuff we have ever seen in this series
and I'll be explaining the latest
chapter which includes suga Rocky's new
quirks his fight with endeavour his
connection to one for all and how back
ago and dec whose lives are now in
genuine danger the full chapter is not
out yet
but what we do have is several leaked
images with Japanese text and a full
chapter summary in English so those are
the two things that will be going
through today but be sure to support the
official release when it comes out on
Sunday on the Shonen Jump app the title
of this chapter is very appropriately
called search now way back in Kamino we
saw the Alpha one had stolen the quark
known as search from rag doll which is a
power that allows her to monitor up to a
hundred people at one time and know
their exact location and their
weaknesses everyone assumed this power
still resided inside all-4-one as you
know he was the one who stole it but
this chapter reveals that sugar rocky
has it and he uses this ability to hunt
down Deku before we get into that part
though the chapter picks up where we
left off on Chapter 273 with endeavour
charging directly at sugar aki with a
clear intent to kill
at this point virtually the entire city
has been destroyed with countless pro
heroes dead including my boy crust and
endeavour thinks to himself that he has
to end it right here right now so that
sugar aki can't escape endeavour
launches a new attack called hell's
curtain which surrounds shigaraki
in a gigantic wall of high-temperature
flames he then gears up to give a jet
burn attack which is one that he
previously used against the high-end
nomu
however shigaraki lunges towards
endeavour before he can release her and
he attempts to grab end of his face and
decay him luckily the number one dodges
the attack literally like Keanu Reeves
but it's at this moment that we get a
look at sugar Rocky's new quirk
despite all the flames around him
Shigure aki is as fine as ever like he
seemingly suffered no damage at all
which means that he has a regeneration
quirk and in devil would know that all
too well because obviously he fought
against this higher nomu with the same
regeneration so he
defies it and he's the one who calls out
as being that because of this the number
one changes his course of action and
decides that instead of trying to burn
sugar Aki he'll use brute force to punch
him into the ground below so what he
does he uses flames to like fly a blood
sugar Aki and then when he's in the air
he pummels him right into the center of
this giant rock and this rock right here
is actually all that remains of Jackie
Hospital like everything else has been
completely decayed by shigaraki he then
shoots his flames directly into the rock
and radios the remaining heroes trying
to warn them that anyone who's capable
of flying or just levitating and
avoiding the ground they may soon need
to join the battle against sugar Aki
despite that his transmission is cut off
when a seemingly fireproof shigaraki he
emerges out of the flames and then
attempts to grab endeavours wrist and
decay him again
Shigure Aki seems to really want this
guy dead thanks to endeavours
lightning-fast reflexes though he stops
himself from getting killed by grabbing
sugar Rocky's arm and preventing the
hand from making contact and in normal
circumstances that would be a great
thing because you know you would have
neutralized the threat but in this case
we see another one of sugar Rocky's
brand-new quarks which is some sort of
energy blast that emits out of his hand
directly in endeavors face this sends
him crashing through the rock which has
really taken a beating today and then
Endeavor hits the ground with a large
thud and then just bounces on the ground
for a little bit this is the number one
hero guys he's getting tossed around by
a 20 year old kid it's insane sugar Aki
notes how his instincts feel almost
all-powerful and that this is likely the
result of all the ones saving up all
those quirks all that experience within
the original offer one quirk which
obviously shigaraki now possesses from
this wording it's implied that the blast
he just used against endeavour wasn't
actually a conscious decision but rather
it was more of an automatic reaction so
like his body just automatically did it
he didn't need to think much like how
one floor contains the spirits of the
previous users in some way it seems that
all for one contains the judgment the
reflexes and the experience of his
previous user sugar Aki then pockets a
few of the quirk destroying bullets
which were being stored in this machine
over here now it was interesting to note
that in Chapter two hundred and seventy
two exes actually destroyed this machine
but at the time we didn't know what it
was then in the last chapter we found
out that it was the machine being used
to replicate the quote destroying
bullets shigaraki takes what's remaining
which is about three or so quite
destroying bullets after he does that he
then reaches over into a box and pulls
out one of the hands of his family
members I'm assuming that's just gonna
go on his face a bit later but yeah I
guess it's worth mentioning something
really strange begins to happen after
this though his whole body starts
regenerating but the way it's drawn it
kind of looks like the way Dec who
looked after he went infinite 100% like
they're just this weird electricity
looking substance all over his face and
it's kind of unclear what it actually is
I'm not gonna lie when I first read this
I had this just crazy thought I was
thinking that all for one was actually
beginning to take over suga Rocky's body
and I thought he was kinda like
transforming in this moment but once I
put my thinking hat on and read the rest
of the chapter it was pretty obvious
that wasn't the case endeavor then gets
back up as he always does and charges
directly at suga Rocky only this time
shaggy is able to hold him back with
just one hand
in the last chapter there was a voice
that appeared in suga Rocky's head
against his will and in this chapter it
makes yet another appearance in this
moment when he's fighting endeavor and
it says that of all the powers I
obtained there was an unexpected force
that I could not wield the voice is then
about to say one for all but is cut off
when Shigure aki decides to take control
of his own mind i'm curious to know
whether this is just the memories of all
the one or if the current of one who's
in jail is somehow sending this message
to sugar aki regardless chicky himself
acknowledges that he's changing like
there's something inside him that's
driving him forward to obtain a certain
power he hears these thoughts in his
head and he says out loud one for all
naturally endeavour hears this but
obviously he knows nothing about one for
all so he just says like in confusion
he's like one for all what was that and
this is transmitted over the radio to
all the heroes and Deku just freezes in
horror from his perspective he's never
told Endeavour about one for all so this
is a pretty freaky thing to be hearing
through the radio and it likely means
that Shigure aki is look
for the quirk this moment is when we see
the search quark in action and remember
that like the chapter is called search
this is a really important thing
Shigure aki begins to look for one for
all and the way the quark works is that
he sees lots of bright shining lights in
the city below with each of these lights
seemingly representing one person and of
all the lights that are there one is
clearly shining brighter than the rest
of them this is of course deku and one
for all and Schick rocky has the biggest
smile on his face once he realizes who
this is the last time these two met
shaker Aki did say that Deku would die
so perhaps this smile is just the
enjoyment of realizing he'll be able to
fulfill his promise and also steel deck
whose quark in the process if Shigure
Aki was to take one for all to get one
for all by yeah you know threatening
back ago and making Deku pass over the
quark to save his life something like
that if that was to happen
I reckon every could come in quite
useful in rewinding Deku it wasn't too
long ago that we got the reveal that
area is training with Aizawa so perhaps
that was a almost like a foreshadow of
her having to put her powers into action
pretty soon to help Deku anyway Shikha
rocky decides to go immediately after
Deku he doesn't really have time to
waste fighting with endeavor anymore and
he uses a quirk that is very similar to
miracle
egg rock he crouches down on the ground
and then jumps into the sky and as he's
gliding through the air you see that the
jump created some kind of sonic boom so
like the force of his legs jumping up
was just incredibly powerful the force
needed to do this would surely be the
result of some kind of strength in
hearts and in quark or maybe even a
mutation quark that's held within all
for one that gives him super strong legs
as he heads directly towards the city
endeavour follows behind him and once
the heroes over the radio that they need
to expand their plans for the evacuation
zone and basically just get everyone out
of there as soon as you can as the
heroes and citizens begin to leave Deku
is still deep in for but you know being
a true hero that he is he turns around
and decides to face shigaraki head on
back ago immediately joins him by a side
as I'm assuming that all the heroes have
that earpiece so they all heard what
Endeavor said but obviously only back
ago and Deku truly knows what it means
the two of them vowed to protect one for
all and blast into the sky leave
all the other students behind we then
get a panel of a choco and this was
really well drawn because you can tell
exactly what she's feeling her concern
for deku in this moment is clearly very
intense but you can also tell she's a
little bit confused as to why he's doing
this the two of them decide that they
should lead Shigure Aki to a deserted
area and according to the plot summary
Deku is genuinely concerned about how
they're gonna actually capture shigaraki
given that he has all these new powers
and so he tries to think of abstract
ways to capture him from my perspective
without professor eyes or were there
you're not realistically gonna capture
shigaraki alive the chapter ends with
these two asking the rest of the guys to
believe in them and shigaraki notices
that dec who's going off in a different
direction
so now suga Rocky's following deku
endeavors following shigaraki and back
you go and Deku are heading to the same
location I think that with Deku endeavor
and Baku go teaming up against sugar Aki
it will appear perhaps the next chapter
that they have the upper hand and
perhaps it might even look like they're
about to be him that is until giganto
machia shows up with the rest of the
league of villains and this is something
that sugar Aki asked again to mark here
to do in the last chapter so he will
show up it's just a question of when the
moment he does that's when the tide of
battle will turn yet again chapter 274
for me it's like the beginning of the
end of this arc you have several ongoing
storylines that will be wrapped up in
the upcoming chapters and I'm not just
talking about the dabby equals Toya
thing I'm also thinking about the quote
destroying bullets you know why did
sugar Aki take those in this moment and
also just sugar Aki trying to acquire
the power of one for all I think if he
was successful in doing that that would
not only be the end of the arc but I
think that my backer go time-travel
theory might actually be falling into
place but that's a story for another
time we'll see how things go over the
next few weeks that's all for me today
guys be sure to subscribe and also turn
on notifications as I have a video
coming relatively soon about a potential
miner academia spin-off so until then
peace up